Clark County going all in on combating
climate change today County
Commissioners adopting a community
sustainability and climate action plan
consisting of multiple goals some
include clean and reliable energy
sources connected and Equitable Mobility
noting that 36 percent of greenhouse gas
emissions for Clark County are
Transportation related next up
sustainable water systems and increasing
the number of smart buildings and homes
in Clark County
RTC Southern Nevada also conducting a
heat mapping study to show which parts
of the valley are the very hottest the
results find that parts of downtown Las
Vegas downtown Newark Las Vegas the
historic west side and Eastern parts of
the valley are hottest due to the large
percentage of pavement lower elevations
and lack of trees a four million dollar
Federal grant will fund more shaded
waiting areas along with more frequent
routes in those areas during the hot
summer season find out how hot your
neighborhood is over on 8newsnow.com